i am really close with my grandfather he
just turned 85. so when i was thinking
about the type of company that i wanted
to build and the type of person i wanted
to build for i think about my grandpa
i grew up really close with my
grandfather from the time that he was in
his 90s
and i saw him really struggle to get the
care that he needed that motivated me to
dive deep and figure out how can i start
a company that makes this better
[Music]
sarah and i met at an admitted students
event before stanford even started when
we were applying to the gsb
independently each of us wrote our
essays about why we wanted to start a
company in healthcare we were at a happy
hour and sarah overheard me say i'm
coming to stanford because i want to
start a healthcare company and i think i
ran across the room
we knew pretty quickly that we wanted to
start a company together it was very
clear to us that we wanted to build an
impact-oriented company that made health
care better for older adults
[Music]
at ferris street we help seniors enroll
in the right health insurance plan and
we do that by empowering independent
insurance agents with the tools they
need to run their business and serve
more seniors
what we realized after doing a couple
hundred interviews with seniors all
across the country is that the universal
pain point is how to navigate the
overwhelming nature of medicare
enrollment from there we looked at well
who had a really good experience
enrolling in medicare and who didn't and
the people who had the best experiences
were the ones who worked with these
local independent agents so what we did
is we went out and we interviewed
hundreds of independent insurance agents
and figured out that they lack any kind
of software to run their business
and so that's exactly where we saw an
opportunity the software that we built
is a revolution for these amazing
independent agents to be able to run
their business
[Music]
the best compliment we've ever gotten
from a senior is saying that was easy i
feel confident i know how to use my
medicare plan i feel like i'm set up for
the right healthcare
so stanford teaches us to dream really
big in changing lives organizations and
the world i think a lot about our role
in changing organizations a big
motivator for me personally in starting
a company is to form and create an
organization that i would have always
wanted to work at as an employee and as
two female co-founders ourselves it's
something that we think a lot about is
how do we create an inclusive culture an
equitable culture a culture where
everyone can get to show up and do the
best work of their lives
before coming to the gsb i thought that
business was very strict and very
factual and at the gsb you learn about
how much emotion
and feelings play into what goes on in a
business my grandfather would definitely
be proud of fair street and i think that
the thing he would hope for the most is
that other people
have a better healthcare experience than
he did
our whole family would have liked to
spend the last years of my grandfather's
life
together as a family and
not trying to
wade through medical bills and medical
decisions if he could see other families
having that better experience i'm sure
he would be very proud
for our ambition to change the world
we're just getting started our hope is
that
if we're successful every single person
turning 65 does not have to worry about
their health care that they're taken
care of by fair street and by one of the
amazing agents that we work with so that
they can have health care for the rest
of their life
my name is sarah jacobson i'm the
co-founder and ceo of fair street my
name is tori seidenstein and i'm the
co-founder and cto of fair street
you